And the answer is 14 messages. And the first message
Alice is essentially telling onion router 1 to tell onion router 2
to extend onion router 3. Then onion router 1 tells
onion router 2 to extend onion router 3.
And the third message onion router 2 tells onion router 3
to create a circuit. Onion router 3 responds onion router 2
saying I’ve created it. Onion router 2 responds back to
onion router 1 saying I’ve extended. And onion router 1
responds back to Alice saying that I’ve extended.
To then extend on to onion router 4, there will be two new
messages between onion router 3 and onion router 4.
So takes six messages to extend to onion router 3 and eight
more messages to extend onion router 4 to get 14.